really good to be here
this is Annie go go we're on there yeah
we're on a mission to empower people to
unite around the ideas that matter to
them and together bring those ideas to
life what we stand for is we believe
every idea deserves a shot if you're
willing to work hard if you're willing
to hustle it's not luck it's not
privilege that shouldn't matter it
should be how hard are you willing to
work to bring your idea to life and the
reason I'm really passionate about this
is this is a fun clicker the reason I
really fast about this is because I grew
up watching my parents struggle for 30
years trying to bring their business to
life and grow their business from a
small business into a larger business
and it sucked it was hard hurdles every
step of the way
funding being a huge one of them and
then when I got to New York and started
understanding money and started working
with actually filmmakers and theatre
producers on the side I ran into the
exact same challenges I actually had
this event where I got a theatre like
this with an audience like this we put
up a one-night event of an Arthur Miller
play about racial profiling this was
right after September 11th I got
investors there to witness the whole
thing so that they loved it and write
the check at the end of the night based
on the audience response and everything
went perfect except that last moment
when they said this was amazing we're
not investing good luck not our cup of
tea and it was in that moment that I
realized why entrepreneurship was so
freaking hard it's because the people
who wanted something to come to life in
this case the actors and the audiences
they didn't actually have the power to
make it happen and they were completely
dependent on these other third party
gatekeepers so that's what we changed
I've teamed up with my co-founders which
is a whole nother story and together we
launched IndieGoGo today we've had over
5,000 a hundred thousand campaigns in
every country of the world I'd even know
there's more than 200 and almost a
billion dollars distributed and we're
actually two sites now we have IndieGoGo
calm which is really focused on all of
our entrepreneurial ideas filmmakers
startups drones whatever you want to
bring to life we help you coffee shops
it's all they are and generosity which
is our free sister site for personal
causes nonprofits people doing stuff
more focused on
on I'm bring good into the world and so
in the process of starting IndieGoGo
though we actually ended up inventing an
industry as Sam called it and we have
people like the prior speakers come up
and have enormous success getting their
businesses off the ground this way and
in the process we've also done something
amazing which I'm personally proud of is
we have removed the requirements of luck
and Prejudice and all that in your
success now it just means you have to
hustle and for that reason we have
things like on any gogo 41% of all the
campaigns they reach their funding
target that are entrepreneurial are run
by women but in venture capital world
that's only less than 10% a lot of bias
there but what IndieGoGo is proving is
that women hustle just as much as men
and we're just as entrepreneurial and
because of that we're just as successful
and in the process now what we've
realized is we're actually doing it
again and we're doing more than just
funding we invented crowdfunding almost
ten years ago and now we're actually
branching out we're actually helping
customers all throughout the entire
journey from start to finish we're doing
work with partnerships like with
Brookstone and manufacturers to help
products once they get their funding to
go all the way to the finish line and
become really big businesses which is
amazing and we're doing it again so what
I want to talk to you guys about today
is the challenge for us is there's no
blueprint for inventing industries we're
not trying to be a better faster cheaper
version of something else we're trying
to do something a whole new way and for
that the way you you solve that is it
all comes down to your team who's your
team and they've three ingredients of a
team that can innovate and figure this
out our diversity mission and values
diversity stat is the statistics are out
there something's not popping up but it
has been proven time and time again the
more diverse your team the more
productive you are the more creative you
are the more engaged they are the more
innovative you are so the key is when
you're starting a company make it
diverse at IndieGoGo and was 50% of our
team is women that's crazy in the tech
land but I think it's because of that
that we've been so effective of actually
serving our customers and maybe that's
why women are so successful in IndieGoGo
the key tips here and how you how do you
become diverse there's a lot of great
research you want to cast your wide net
you want to make sure you remove all
unconscious bias from the hiring process
but you guys are startup you're hustlers
your you know teams of ones and two here
you don't have masses but massive
budgets to go recruit and hire anybody
you want so my tip here is the way to
okay sorry about that the way to get
around that is just start to burst when
you start to verse you're basically your
recruiting strategy is who are your
friends who's in your network who's your
friends on Facebook and so if you start
diverse then you actually will recruit
diverse and you'll build a team that
actually is a bunch of people who think
different act different come from
different backgrounds believe different
things have different skill sets look
different all that good stuff plus
unconscious bias is something that's
really really freaking hard we all are
biased I'm biased just admit it
we spent a lifetime understanding what
our biases and let's be conscious to
them but at least when you start diverse
and have a group of people with all
kinds of biases it evens out so no one
bias can control the others and send you
want to put on a path to building a non
innovative company the second ingredient
to building an innovative team is having
a really strong mission and hiring
people that are mission driven so
clearly we've done a lot of work to
really focus on why we exist that's to
unite people around the ideas that
matter to them and empower them to bring
those people those ideas to life notice
funding is not in this title because
we're doing more than funding but
because of that we've attracted the most
amazing mission driven people and the
reason why you need mission driven
people is because when you're innovating
and creating something you don't have
this blueprint and you have all these
diverse people so you have lots of
different ambitious ideas what brings
them all together and what focuses them
is your is your mission is your guiding
light plus when people are Purpose
Driven they are far more productive far
more creative and far more innovative so
that is what you want to do and they're
really good at opportunity spotting
which is what innovation is again it's
you're not following any blueprint so my
advice to you and how to make sure your
you have a good mission is just ask
yourself five the five why's why are you
doing this ask yourself again and again
and again and get yourself to a point
where the answer to why you're starting
this business or this company that
you're doing is
an irrational belief it's just what you
believe there's no rationality involved
and if you can get to a place like that
you know you've got a strong lie and
that will be the guiding light for your
company the third ingredient of an
innovative team is culture it's it's the
culture is what brings everybody
together and culture is not ping pong
tables it's not free food yes that's
part of it maybe a lot here in some
tally but that is not what culture is
culture are your values when you have a
diverse group of people who are
ambitious about trying to achieve
something really massive which is your
mission this is on the left is what
happens they will want to go every
different direction but it's your values
it's your culture which is I think one
in the same that bring everybody into
alignment for us fearlessness for
example is one of our values and what
that means is that tert fearlessness at
IndieGoGo means turning challenges into
opportunities to innovate when people
share their values even though they have
different opinions and different
backgrounds and look different but when
they share their values they actually
can get something done together imagine
if you're someone who likes to innovate
and every time you see a challenge and
you see that as an opportunity to do
something new and you're trying to work
with someone who runs into a challenge
and they see it as a reason to give up
that's very frustrating so when you have
when you're clear on what your values
are people when they're working together
spend more time actually getting work
done than figuring out how to work
together and it's clear companies with
strong cultures
once again completely outperform our
more innovative creating way more value
than companies without a lot of data so
how do you do that we've put ourselves
through an exercise okay we put
ourselves through an exercise very early
on in IndieGoGo and that's where we
basically sat ourselves down and asked
ourselves to draw up six pictures that
answer the questions I love coming to
work at IndieGoGo because and in that
process we did a little show-and-tell it
was really funny I learned that design
was not a strength on our team and they
were gonna have to figure that out soon
but we learned that we all came to work
for the same four reasons and that was
we wanted to change an industry we
weren't afraid of doing it fearlessness
we wanted to bring our whole selves to
work not wear any kind of physical or
metaphorical uniforms anymore
we wanted to be authentic we wanted to
work with others and win with others
playing alone solo sports not our thing
we liked winning together we'd like to
collaborate and empowerment we wanted to
spend our waking days helping people
that wanted to be helped you guys
wanting to bring your ideas to life
empowerment and then the next step we
did which didn't happen right away but
took a few years and this is why I'm
sharing this is our learnings is then
once you start to hire people and get to
you know dozens you know we're now over
a hundred people you need to actually
articulate what behaviors that must
people embody every single day to truly
exhibit and embody these values and so
we did work even but got the entire
company we went through in a painstaking
way and really distilled from us what is
it that we do when we're performing at
our best being the most creative most
innovative most collaborative all this
stuff what is it that we're doing that
makes it worth it and we clarified those
behaviors we put them on paper and we
hold ourselves to it from there you then
hire for this fit you don't just hire
for skills fit but you get really
ruthless about hiring people for culture
fit which is literally those who
authentically embody your values you
don't want to change anybody once they
hire once you hire them you want them to
bring their authentic self and if
they're getting to be themselves and
feel whole at work they will be again
more alive more engaged more productive
and then you want to recognize people
for it we have it can be very heavy I
don't recommend that it can be a very
lightweight way to just honor the people
when somebody really shows their
fearlessness or shows their
collaboration we honor it every quarter
we have eggies it's a ton all hands
people just give awards out to each
other for folks who are examples of
embodying our values and when you do
that the last thing you want to do I
know culture and all this stuff feels
very soft it's really not this is again
crucial to growth and actually
innovating and build something
meaningful and you can actually measure
it and we do so again the point of
innovation is you have to be you want
people engaged and the more engaged they
are the more productive and we measure
both for example we've created an
employee NPS survey that everybody takes
once a month and we do report cards on
ourselves in our productivity how well
are we achieving our goals Gordon Lee
and ironically I actually just did a
quick r-squared correlation analysis the
better we perform more effectively are
the more engaged we are the r-squared is
quite high the correlation is quite high
so I just want to leave you with
my final thoughts here it's all you know
hustling here we're trying to start
stuff we're trying to innovate we're
trying to build new things just want to
remind you that the point of all of this
the point is not just to be innovative
the point is not just to be
entrepreneurial don't become an
entrepreneur because you want to be an
entrepreneur don't become an
entrepreneur because you just want to
innovate always remember that innovation
or entrepreneurship journey is a means
to a greater end it so it means that
mission and if you remember that you
actually can do something great and if
you forget you'll get lost and you won't
be successful and then people like this
will start talking to you stop talking
about you which this just happened so
thank you for your time today good luck
we are all about empowering
entrepreneurs we have team in San
Francisco that will help you all kinds
of resources email me at today at
IndieGoGo calm if you want to get
connected to anybody thank you